next we got Brock this is our boy Bryan
gang boy rock what's up Bri Oh what's up
finding my name's Brock I'm here in
Sacramento California a huge fan of you
guys thank you so much for the podcast
it is absolutely [ __ ] awesome I had a
little King it or sting it for you guys
today my question is what are your
thoughts on webbed toes oh hell yeah
where's the web at in the middle you see
it mmm bang bang good guys right here
dude all right there okay oh they're
just stuck together on he drew a little
dotted line yeah dude I'm a fan of
webbed toes I wish I had some I'd swim
better it makes you unique I did a kick
a ball hard or fat farther I doesn't
Michael Phelps have webbed toes I don't
know probably probably think it's wet I
think only has one big leg like it is
wet bags a fireman um does he uh flip
those sighs join it mm-hmm
get out of the water cheating dude six
insane facts about my hope that makes
his feet flippers because he can oh look
images of Michael Phelps web toast yeah
I knew you had web no way yeah cheater
get the images out Derek that can't be
without real I'm pretty sure he is like
one two web toes but my [ __ ] are
freak there they are that's a that's a
corn that one you ever had a corner
bunion no I've worked on a farm though
we ate corn Milo Otis cotton Wow look at
that yeah easy to swim when you [ __ ]
aren't even aren't even supposed to be
on the land she was born like that dude
yeah fish when you're freaking cousins a
salamander this [ __ ] is [ __ ] dude
look at him it's not a but what is that
it's not an adult male that is a water
that's a dolphin human yeah it's a water
man look at that Wow super flexible we
got big his hands are got we get the
quads on that fish dude I would yeah you
could easily make a nice fillet out of
that man's leg if I'm in a plane crash
and that dudes
in there do I mean him like a sword
first [ __ ] first do before the gun even
sounds I'm [ __ ] dice no flounder yeah
she'll flounder just Jesus Christ I'll
read them I'm all about webbed feet make
sure you knee can swim like a
[ __ ] it's a conversation starter
I think this man I think this I think
you just have to be careful because you
could almost be giving Satan a head
start brother you know what I mean your
your you know your hat your you know
dark arts on the feet you're 5% in a
witchcraft rather people see that at the
beach or they see that at the pool
basically the Witch of 2019 yeah you
can't be tying a dreamcatcher to the
back in truck and just cruising around
town you know yeah yeah you should get a
stable job and then you sit out that's
all I'm saying is balance it out there's
nothing wrong with you but the way
people perceive you is gonna be really
could be a bit hectic can you wear
sandals huh
probably not here you can I have sandals
on right now you good no not just oh god
your feet what's wrong with your
neighbor my father speed freak you're
gonna head feet up in Denver dude
400,000 feet good luck with your feet
man Kenya a couple pieces of beef jerky
at the end of your legs boy yeah Melanie
ain't got nothing on these sirloin
hitters daddy look at that what is that
nothing ooh ooh do they spin in swamp
water huh just look keeping the
underwater friends bro these are 40%
Spanish small son oh what's up dog gang
don't hit all the buttons
[Music]
the king nothing
[Music]